[Music]
good morning John it's Thursday December
27th now let us go back in time to a
more innocent age an age when I had
never played a live gig or blended
Strawberry Hill and peeps
dangerously fizzy maybe let us dissolve
we didn't know how to discuss how many
peeps needed to be put in the Strawberry
Hill maybe two is enough I could boil in
the Strawberry Hill I'm not going to bed
early because that's going to take some
time to settle ooh now I'm going to film
Katherine boring the mixture back into
the Strawberry Hill bottle because my
hands are very shaky as you can see
because I'm so nervous
this gums not going in that's good I
don't like to scum the scum is going in
go in into the bottle cheap juice oh it
looks like throw-up no don't say that
in retrospect the peat blending with the
Strawberry Hill very much like the rest
of that evening loud uncomfortable
hastily put together messy poorly
planned sloppily executed sticky stinky
and the product was more or less similar
to dog vomit I'll show you how it
started because it's pretty much how the
whole thing went I don't even know what
that was and there was some kind of
actual solid ball of fear that my lungs
produced and then they shoved it up
through my mouth not a good thing to
have happen while you're singing and
though that didn't happen to me again it
hasn't ever happened to me in the past
either did find about 37 other ways to
screw up but let's not go through each
and every one of those instead let's
just do a little recap of the concert
Oh
[Music]
qu - ha
why
once the entire winter start from you I
sold your dog on eBay
[Music]
goodbye 26 year old me
trying Jack's cornflakes to taste good
together tonight
Bruce Anstey's
I
my girl farther
it feels like I've been up here for a
few hours now how long has it been this
song is the reason I'm famous
I need Harry Potter like that Saturday a
purse line
younggook sensor part is it
these tears are broken
oh damn we
that is the end of my show tonight folks
kathan to sit on cross horrible Bravo
we love you I like to thank Colin for
helpings of this office with my brother
in the nerdfighters and my wife so what
does Hank post concert think about the
concert I'll be honest it felt pretty
bad it could have been worse yes
Katherine it could have been worse I
could have been hit in the face with a
vial of transmissible cancer but as
concerts go it was pretty bad
there was a nerdfighter there who filmed
the whole thing and has already got it
up on YouTube thanks DJ thanks did you
diva for getting him to come out I'll
put the link down there or over there or
possibly right there so you can watch
the whole horrible mess of it all
thanks for the punishment everyone all
in all a good experience though
officially now not on the list of
possible career choices for me rock star
crossed off the list John and we'll see
your last Brotherhood do bueno video
tomorrow boo